all right we're gonna do a deep dive now
into what is happening psychologically
epistemologically and cognitively with
your average Trump voter right now now
let me set this up for you we're going
to look at a couple of focus groups
groups Foci we might even call them okay
that PBS did with voters
and if I came to you and I said folks
um I'm gonna pull back the curtain and
show you the insanity of the voters who
want a flat tax you would probably look
at me and say David that's not super
interesting like wanting a flat tax even
if I disagree with it it's not really
indicative of something wacky and zany
that's going on and I would agree with
you but we have a situation right now
where we have a twice indicted twice
impeached globally humiliated failed
former president with significant
evidence of criminality against him
innocent until proven guilty of course
running a campaign that is absolute
lunacy and yet there are still
presumably tens of millions of people
that support the guy we're gonna try to
figure out what's going on that's the
introduction let's jump into the video
and then we'll discuss how many of you
know that Donald Trump was indicted last
week raise your hand everybody raises
their hands although some sort of
reluctantly how many of you have heard
that Donald Trump wasn't dead for a
second time recently
and the reason for hearing the questions
twice is there's two focus groups here
and they're switching between the two
everybody knows okay from the 16
Republican voters we gathered yesterday
evening there were strong reactions to
the second indictment of former
president Donald Trump I think he's
being set up oh yeah tell me why well
um it's just too
arranged everything is just too arranged
and when the FBI went in and raided his
property at Mar-A-Lago how do we know
what they did and what they didn't do
right and wrong are just totally messed
up we had asked pollster Sarah Longwell
who also publishes the center right
website the bulwark to assemble two
panels of GOP voters in the studio of
Iowa PBS I observed from the control
room she asked how they're thinking
about politics policy and current events
at this moment candidates are already
descending upon their state ahead of
next year's caucuses and as the news of
the second Trump indictment had been
breaking it's baloney I think I think uh
I mean just why isn't Biden indicted
just because he gave them back
um at an appropriate time I mean really
so he did exactly the same thing well
you have a current president who is
sicking all of the doj on a potential
candidate that's never happened right
right now they really feel like the
country's going in the wrong direction
afterwards Longwell who has conducted
hundreds okay so let's pause there
so asked their thought they all had
heard of the indictment asked about
their thoughts on the indictment they
said it's clearly a setup
the photos appear to have been staged
sort of like we don't know what the FBI
did meaning they staged or set it up in
some way it's baloney Biden did the same
thing and should be arrested or charged
himself Biden sicked the doj on Trump
for which there is quite literally no
evidence whatsoever no evidence
whatsoever let's continue support for
Donald Trump how many of you distrust
the FBI
the three-letter agencies the doj the
CIA the FBI I think when the company of
the country was formulated the best of
intent was to put some of these um
organizations or governing bodies in
place but how they're being manipulated
now and they're being weaponized is the
baker concern this is just straight up
what what Maga has been feeding these
folks these folks have uncritically
accepted these bogus talking points I'm
kind of frustrated by that because on
one side you know it seems like we're
all going all out on President Trump and
on the other side
the wheels of Justice are going very
slow it doesn't seem to be like equal
amount of resources being devoted to
looking into the hunter Biden's laptop
and 100 so
Hunter Biden's laptop is is an issue for
these folks in thinking about what's
going on right now in the Republican
Party about Hillary Clinton
that's all this stuff and she was never
indicted you've got the doj you've got
the FBI reporting up to Biden ultimately
this goes up to Biden so why wouldn't
you want to take out your your toughest
political opponent and this is election
interference like we've never seen
before that is a trump quote I mean
that's that's just that's what Trump
posts to truth Central this is election
interference like we've never seen
before that's where they get this stuff
and it's disguised as Trump's a bad guy
how many of you wanted Hillary Clinton
to be indicted for her uh okay did you
think okay so of the people at the table
uh two of the eight did not raise their
hand that they wanted Hillary indicted
he should go to jail for what she did
absolutely because Trump now that's
interesting
they're saying Hillary should have gone
to jail
Hillary was these are the folks who
claim to be about Law and Order and
bemoan lack of due process when it comes
to Trump they're saying Hillary should
have gone to jail they don't know about
the evidence
they seem not to care that Hillary was
cleared they seem not to know that there
was no chargeable crime that Hillary was
involved in but while saying out of one
side of their mouth we're for Law and
Order and due process and the justice
system working properly they're saying
imprison Hillary Clinton despite the
fact that she was cleared of criminality
I'm uh said that she should go to jail
for mishandling classified information
do you think he should be held to the
same standard that he was setting for
Hillary Clinton or do you think that
it's different for some reason I think
he said that when you understand his
personality and how he
um how he words thinks he said that
ingest so there you that's this that's a
great moment okay this is what we call
cognitive dissonance or magical thinking
depending on your perspective
they're asked you know Trump said
Hillary should also be locked up for
those things but now Trump did it what
about we simply hold Trump to the
standard he said should be applied to
Hillary Clinton and they go well when
Trump said Hillary should be locked up
he was kidding but these folks just said
Hillary should be locked up were they
also kidding 30 seconds earlier it
doesn't matter they're in a world of
their own he didn't I think he's just
trying to paint a word picture but
should she had gotten some sort of uh
punishment yes yes I think so he's
entitled to declassify whatever he wants
to declassify so in other presidents
that have left office have had
classified documents again another
talking point straight from the right
Trump is entitled to declassify things
Trump admits in audio recordings he
didn't declassify those things the
actions for which Trump has been
indicted took place after he was
president when we talk about Obama or
bush and their documents they arranged
with Nara to temporarily store documents
in specific places disclosing where that
was on a temporary basis until they
could be permanently located either at
presidential libraries or other places
it's not true what this guy is saying
but it is in lockstep with what Trump
and Mark Levin and these other
right-wing figures have fed to them they
were not treated the same way as Donald
Trump is being treated it is a two-tier
justice system in this country literally
another word another phrase from Trump
this is what this guy has fallen for all
of it for sure there's no doubt about it
the biggest thing is that all right
let's skip ahead a little bit here to
other moments uh from from the panels if
you're interested in the interview
between Judy Woodruff and um uh the the
pollster Sarah Longwell uh you can you
can check this out it was showing the
Capitol Police walking these people
through the capitol talking
no problems whatsoever this is another
right-wing argument which they have been
fed and have uncritically accepted if
what the rioters did was so wrong why
did the Capitol Police welcome them and
of course once you realize well what was
going on was once police realized
they've been unable they're unable to uh
keep a crowd back then you have to give
way and at that point what you want to
do is keep people calm but the idea was
the Capitol Police thought it was great
they just welcomed the protesters how
can you charge them and then they turn
around and say
they they attacked us right in essence
the videos show a whole different story
than what they're saying happened
arguably once we got the videos from the
January 6 committee what happened is
even worse than what was originally
reported but this guy wants to say it
really wasn't a big deal I personally
don't think that like he was calling
people to like do like I watched like
what he said and everything and like I
mean he didn't say anything to me like
in watching it that was like you know oh
yeah he's telling them to go and like
storm the capital you know like I didn't
feel I personally didn't feel like that
um that what he was said was so
inflammatory that he was just trying to
like you know tear the country apart
they're still arresting people too he
quite literally was trying to overturn
the results of an election he lost if
that's not an action to tear a country
apart I don't know what is two years
right since it happened he loves his
country I can't believe this right well
he owns this country
because right people to fight like that
and he is against Wars this is not the
typical politician and uh his words
aren't what we call polished and he just
blurted out do people want to vote for a
republican candidate who is committed to
pardoning the people from January 6th
yes absolutely yeah that's interesting
they want that they actively want a
candidate who will pardon who will
pardon the rioters they are so convinced
of the Innocence of those individuals
guilty of these charges he goes through
the courts and they find him guilty to
raise your hand if it makes you support
him more
okay the question is if Trump is found
guilty do you support him more remember
due process we're now not talking about
the justice department we're talking
about a jury we're talking about a jury
just like this group of people as scary
as that is finding Trump guilty one two
three four five six of the eight people
say I would support Trump more if he
were found guilty by a jury of his peers
raise your hand if it makes you support
him less
no one
and president Trump retains some measure
of support even among those who think he
likely committed a crime I read the
indictment
um and it's plain as day that he broke
the law knowingly whether the doj
um came after him
uh which I think is very plausible and
why they're ignoring Hunter Biden's
laptop I think is a separate issue
um but it is clear he broke the wall and
I think it's time for him to go away
and uh
I I appreciated what he did for the
country
during his four years
um but I think that he is part of the
problem but when asked if he'd vote for
Trump if he were the nominee running
against President Biden Trump's the
nominee versus Biden what will you do I
would vote for him for the third time he
would
I think that uh it's that significant so
given that and the fact that they're
potential I think you get the picture we
are dealing here this is why at the top
of this segment I said if I told you
guys I've got a group of people that
wants a flat tax check out how insane
this is we would all say that's a very
specific policy disagreement that
doesn't raise the source of moral and
ethical cult type questions that these
focus groups raise what this means for
the Democratic party and the left from a
strategy perspective there's a whole
bunch of stuff culturally
sociologically
anthropologically that is going to take
decades to unwind from this sort of
cultishness I'm not dealing with that
right now what this means from a
political strategy standpoint as I've
said before is that it is not worth the
time to try to convince these folks of
anything
the right way to invest time and
resources for Democrats that want to win
is to work on just getting the vote out
from those who would otherwise stay home
that are as horrified by this stuff as
we are in a country with a 50 to 60
percent turnout rate you don't need to
convince those people you just need to
find folks and say you're not voting
well then one of these people in the
focus group is going to have a say in
how the country is run instead of you
and if that doesn't motivate more people
to vote quite frankly I don't know what
would make sure you're subscribed to our
YouTube channel our we had a forensic
audit done of the YouTube channel last
month we looked for bamboo fibers
barbecue sauce all sorts of stuff all
over YouTube subscriptions what we found
was that last month more than three
million people watched our videos and
did not subscribe if just 10 of those
folks were to subscribe we would get to
our 2 million subscriber goal overnight
help us get there hit that subscribe
button we'll take a quick quick break
and be back with so much more one of our
sponsors today is relief band relief
band is the number one FDA cleared
anti-nausea wristband clinically proven
to effectively prevent nausea and
vomiting relief band is a type of
therapy called transdermal
neuromodulation acue stimulation and in
really simple terms it's just a band you
wear on your wrist that sends a gentle
pulse to the part of your nervous system
that regulates nausea and there's been
growing research showing that relief ban
can help with nausea from motion
sickness from pregnancy and from all
sorts of other situations and a number
of studies suggest relief band can help
with nausea after surgery in conjunction
with medication many people use relief
band for nausea from anxiety or
migraines when you feel sick on a car or
plane or a boat it's simple it's safe
it's drug free and there are no side
effects relief band has an A plus rating
from the Better Business Bureau with
over 100
000 satisfied customers online it's just
a brand you can trust you can go and
read the reviews let relief band help
you make nausea a thing of the past
you'll get 20 off plus free shipping
when you go to reliefband.com and use
the code Pacman at checkout the link is
in the description